a lot of parents biggest mistake is over
emphasizing school because what it does
is it trains a child to believe in
short-term validation School teaches
people to accept and even Aspire towards
subjective affirmation every 90 days on
teaching a commodity it's destroying
children we have destroyed the only
people that achieve remarkable things in
life were the ones that legitimately
either in their mind or through
execution went again it's accepting the
process most don't and then they find
themselves in a place where even
understanding who they are is a
challenge because all they've done is
try to Aspire towards this tangible
outside validation infrastructure that
is not grounded in anything important